[Music]
welcome to the heavy spoiler show i'm
your host paul
in this episode we're breaking down the
new horror his house just in time for
halloween
the movie is really unique in its
concept and it tackles things like
asylum seekers
survivors guilt and just how the system
in general views mental health
throughout the film we follow husband
and wife refugee couple
ball and real who fled to the uk from
sudan
the pair apparently lost their daughter
making the journey but it's later
revealed that they actually took the
child in order to gain access to a bus
that was leaving the war zone either way
the vessel lay crosston ended up
capsizing
and both ball and real have to deal with
the fact that many died in order for
them to find a better life
they must make the most of the
opportunity they've been given
and integrate with the locals even
though they're held back from certain
things
matt smith plays their caseworker and he
grants them with a new home
but makes it very clear that they have
to keep their heads down
not cause any trouble and settle into it
without issue
otherwise they'll be sent back home
smith's character
very much represents how the system can
be warmed to people
but also how it fails them in several
ways when introducing them to the house
upon realizing how broken certain things
are he says he will send someone around
to fix things
but never does still they have this new
life
and i told that they must become some of
the in quotes good ones
will be sent back home now one of the
case workers at one point mutters that
the home the pair have is bigger than
his
and it's very clear that the staff
believe immigrants should be grateful
for whatever they get
even if it's not all sunshine and
rainbows now whilst
most who made the journey woodley about
this chance
things proved to be difficult when the
pair discover that the house is haunted
by a malevolent spirit
known as an apath this ghost hides in
the darkness
and torments the pair by watching them
through the walls
at one point real recounts the story of
an apeth
who one day latched itself onto a thief
taking the subtext here ball and real
very much stole their quote-unquote
daughter away from her mother
and led her to her death which is
clearly why the spirit followed them
the apath is seen almost like a virus
something that will stalk you
until you offer something up to it in
the case of ball
it wants his life and this should very
much be seen as being in exchange for
the life that they
caused to end in order to make this
journey now the epithet brings with it
several specters and spirits that
clearly represent survivors guilt
the ghosts that appear in the house also
take on the faces of those that died in
the voyage
and it's very much hammering homeless
idea that the pair feel a lot of grief
i think that this is hinted at in the
opening of the film when we catch
ball having a nightmare about the
journey and upon waking up he tells his
wife that he was dreaming of their
wedding day
in reality he was haunted by what
happened to them and at one point he
begins to pull a wire out of the wall
which eventually turns into seaweed rial
sees kids sitting in cages
and the apath becomes very much a
manifestation of them coming to terms
with the lives that have been lost
in order for the pair to get a new one
mirroring this the apath itself is
somewhat of an asylum seeker
and it attempts to find a new body in
ball now not only
is this a fish out of what a story it's
also one about how people handle grief
in different ways
and both ball and real have opposing
ideologies
real hates england and she's pretty much
left on her own for most of the day
tormented by the ghosts in the house and
fantasies of home
she's mocked by black british youths and
realizes that even people who should
perhaps be able to see things from her
perspective
hate her just as much as the prejudice
white people do
now immigration refugees and asylum
seekers
are always a hot topic and just this
week in england there have been several
reports surrounding them
it often feels like there's a real lack
of empathy towards refugees
and even when a migrant died recently
there were several people on social
media making fun of them
and saying things like great news let's
hope for more
it really is disgusting to see people
acting like this openly
and it's sad how the internet has
brought out some of the worst in
humanity
now i love that the film portrayed just
how harrowing it was for people who
wanted a better life
and the only thing that separated us
from them was that they weren't lucky
enough to be born here
i think this is what real really
struggles with and the stigma that is
attached to asylum seekers
coupled with the house just makes her
want to return home
he holds on to dolls and necklace that
are symbols of home
and clearly refuses to let go ball burns
these as he believes that they've been
mocked
but clearly real is stubborn about
moving on and even takes one of the
totems back
juxtaposing this ball will do whatever
he can to integrate
he sings football chants about peter
crouch gets friendly with the locals
and at one point even goes to a clothes
shop and buys the same things that he
sees in a picture
of what he deems as the typical british
man however he
isn't really accepted and in the
background we can see as one of the
security guards stalk him
likely spared on by his own personal
prejudices
it's a much needed conversation to have
but the film
doesn't beat you over the head with it
it's simply there as a part of the
pair's life
now as the house gets worse and worse
their mental state does too
i very much viewed its decaying and the
ghosts starting to come in more and more
as a symbol of how their mental health
was starting to slip
rial spends her days in fantasies
remembering her home
and balls sees more and more demons
lurking in the shadows
he attempts to get them a new home but
because of the dangers that seeming
crazy would cause
he acts really weird which in turn
causes more issues
i love how the danger in the film not
only comes from the house itself
but also the position that they are in
socially and the movie does a great job
of providing tension at every turn
now in the climax we indeed discover
that they took someone's daughter away
from their mother
and the apath promises that if baal
takes his own life
that the child will be returned to them
this spirit too goes to real
and tries to get her to kill him as we
learn that the spectre is powerless to
do anything itself
and instead it must use others to get
what it wants the pair wrestle back and
forth over whether they should give ball
to the creature
and he eventually cuts himself so that
it can climb into him
it bursts out the floor and grabs him as
real leaves
however she comes back and kills the
yappeth before it can take over his body
now this is very much a union between
the pair and throughout the film we've
watched as they've pretty much been
apart from one another in the way
they've processed their new life
however this coming together shows that
they can handle it if they work as a
couple
real says goodbye to what she wants and
she leaves not only the child
but also the visions of sudan and says
that she's going home
the use of the word home is very
important here as at no point has she
referred to britain as her home
but clearly she's accepted this new life
and now wants to make something of it
with ball
after the app it dies we see as mark
their case worker comes to their home
with some investigators to look over the
property the walls have been repaired
real and bala together and mark says
they seem well
this is the first time that he's really
noted this and rial says that she has
plans to paint the room
which shows that she's now fully willing
to make her life there
balls says that he still sees the ghosts
and that it was only when he let them
in and accepted the guilt that he was
able to face himself
it's a really touching moment that shows
both he and real have accepted that the
past will never go away
but they have accepted it in some form
and are ready to do the best they can
they patched up the walls covered up the
hole in the floor
and stand is a testament to those that
have died they see this spirit surround
them
and we know that though they will live
with them forever they have at least
moved on from the survivor's guilt that
plagued them
and are ready to start something new now
before we get into the review i just
want to remind you that if you haven't
subscribed to us yet
then now's the perfect time to do it as
we do in-depth breakdowns on all the
latest movies and tv shows
we've got a lot of things coming up and
you definitely don't want to miss it
so yeah appreciate you doing it anyway
that's the main plot of the film
and what i took from it but what did i
think of the movie overall
well i have to say that i really enjoyed
his house and after finishing it it
feels like one of the best
if not the best horror of the air it
took me a while to remember that the
invisible man came out early 2020
but in my opinion it's very close
between the two
refugees are often dehumanized i think
that this does a brilliant job of
actually painting out a side to them
that we never really see the media often
cover their struggles
but we never hear from the people
themselves and this is a much needed
film
especially with all that's going on it's
excellently acted
easy to follow but also very deep in its
subtext
and double meaning i absolutely love
unique horrors like this
and film set in england instantly make
them more endearing to me
this is a movie about love loss and also
grief
and handles every element of it really
well without being too on the nose or
over the top
it's scary but it also has a heart to it
and getting attached to these characters
and their plea was easy
which is a testament to their
performances the movie does so much with
so little
and it's very difficult to fault really
in any way
his house was excellent and it gets an
8.5 out of 10.
now obviously i'd love to hear your
thoughts on the movie and what you took
from its ending
make sure you comment below and let me
know and if you enjoyed this video then
check out our breakdown of this weekend
so the big release the mandalorian which
is going to be linked at the end
if you want to support the channel and
get to see content early then please
consider
clicking the join button below you can
also come chapters on our discord server
linked in the description
or heavy spoilers on twitter thanks for
making it until the end of the video
you've been the best i've been paul i'll
see you next time
take care peace
[Music]
you